hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2013 you're
watching the GameSpot stage my name is
daniel wire and i am absolutely
delighted to be joined by michael
macmaine hi how you doing the crater of
lich them battle mage or one of the many
craters of Lichtenberg matrix and this
is a game which we have been playing a
lot of in the GameSpot office it's also
one that we like to call Lich them
battle mache that also if you want to
release style in Europe has that name I
think it work
and it's a really gorgeous looking game
yeah I know we've got a new fancy player
on the game spot stream so before I get
into the nitty gritty I think we should
just check out the gameplay and you
explain exactly what we're looking at
here so we've got Josh van belt our
producer playing here and this is a new
level that we just added to our alpha
release which is coming out this Monday
cool the full release of the game is in
August 26 you guys have been in steam
early access for a couple of months now
right for yeah about 12 weeks okay so
and this represents our third release
the one that's coming out next week so
this is a third level that we've added
to the gameplay here and it's called the
Maelstrom and it's a kind of an
underground area where the magic a
cataclysmic event it happened a long
time ago and we've got this whirlpool
that's all frozen solid with all the
ships and everything in it so you're
making your way to the bottom of it and
first thing to say about this is I I
remember seeing this in person a couple
of weeks ago it looks absolutely
gorgeous yeah this is CryEngine is all
right that is correct yes
and so has that allowed you to do stuff
do you think you haven't seen in any
other first-person role-playing magic
yeah yeah there's no doubt that you know
CryEngine has really helped us to
achieve a visual style that's very
stunning and very different from
everything else and we've tried to sort
of make it our own right give it our own
look and we worked very hard at that so
the interesting thing about Alysha
battle mages as the rpgs almost the the
first choice you make is deciding what
type of character you want to be and not
that that isn't the case here there
certainly is customization but I guess
Steve if there was a USP you've little
battle mages that you were friggin
really powerful mage that's correct
you bet you play as a mage we call it
being an unmitigated badass okay Opie
mage that's right and so within that
class though you are able to forge your
own magic spells in one right and what
we did
you know we looked at this and we said
what do people typically do with mages
they put constraints on them like
cooldowns and mana bars you have them
equal to other classes we remove all of
that we take that away and usually
people say well doesn't that mean the
games gonna be easy but it's very
challenging it's it's a challenging game
so you're saying that like the sort of
downsizing of mages in other games is a
design based entirely on the existence
of the other characters kind of correct
and you know how do how do we learn how
to play mages and games we learn by
doing things like kiting yeah and
running away right because you can't let
anything touch you you're a glass cannon
right well we wanted to deliver
something different we want to deliver a
titanium cannon so we weaponize your
defensive ability so you can stand
toe-to-toe with your enemies and bring
the fight right into them let's look at
this stuff The Critic customization with
this velcro stick is read incredible so
what josh is doing right here is he's
crafting himself a new shield we've got
three different shields styles for the
type of gameplay you want whether you
want to be toe-to-toe and tanky and
stand up front with the enemies or
strategic and far off and laying waste
to them with large AO ease so he's
crafting some different spells he's
making himself a mastery ice spell or in
this case of destruction ice spells so
he can nuke his enemies really hard I
want to remind the folks I don't know if
you have any questions from Michael
please send them to me ask Donnie
O'Dwyer on Twitter and I'll make sure I
put them over as quickly as possible
and so you guys are ready to be close to
launch this is coming out later this
year like 12 weeks yeah how long even
working on mr. baumann so it's a little
over two years that doesn't seem like an
extraordinarily long amount of time well
we did have some R&D in the beginning
that we had about a couple of years
while we were trying to figure out
exactly what type of game we wanted to
build yeah we knew from the beginning I
knew immediately I wanted to play to
create a mage game that's my passion
that I love but this game what we're
looking at here has been in production
for about two years and the environment
here is absolutely gorgeous I remembers
when we showed on the lobby a number of
weeks ago it was a much less snowy much
more fall in a rich environment right
and can you talk a little bit about the
scale of the world how the levels are
put together and the different types of
robot yes so we have a very crafted
approach to our game play and that you
know you enter your level and you move
your way through it and we have some
exploration areas and so forth the
levels are
to give you somewhere between three to
four hours of play each our total
gameplay experience is gonna be about 30
hours oh wow okay
so do you expect Azzurri is it a linear
progression in terms of storyline as
well is there an end game that you were
eventually gonna yeah so we have this
concept of you play through a story and
then there's a New Game+ kind of mode
where you're able to play and continue
to get more powerful ooh face more
powerful challenges bosses that scale
bigger and and you guys have been very
good with your community it seems it's
one of the may be the benefits of steam
early access and you guys seem to have
embraced it and listening to community
about what they want is this the type of
game that when you guys come in in
August you're going to continue to
release new levels and absolutely yeah
yeah we're very interested in that one
of my many titles is associative
community manager I'm very active out
there with the peer community because
that's it that's that's how you get this
you know we look at we've gone through
two different releases to our community
in early access and this will be our
third one this is fundamentally
different than what you guys looked at
the last time yeah there's a lot of
changes to this and that all came from
the community rather than the players
yeah their feedback in fact one of the
sigils that we added to the game is
lightning we brought in four of our
hardcore players our advocates
yeah brought him into a developer
Roundtable and they designed the like
really yes that's incredible yeah that's
not very often and one of the most
interesting things about this I was
talking to you before we went live is
that this is actually the first game
you've ever worked on that is correct
you additionally you hadn't we do have a
lot of industry veterans yes the first
four yeah I don't think you guys just
picked up CryEngine and came in this
beauty but yeah you had a whole
different career before that is correct
and this is something that you you
dreamt about doing your entire life yeah
I'm an avid gamer like I said I game of
30 to 40 hours a week myself and I have
my whole life and when the previous
business that I was in when we were
finished with that I had an opportunity
to take the team and put him whenever
whatever we wanted to do I said let's
make a game that's incredible so a lot
of this so you worked in some sort of
software but these are guys who a lot of
some of made games and some of them
never made games yeah well our core team
is an engineering team and then we went
out and pulled some real industry
veterans so that's excellent do you mind
me I hate
pairing games with other games because
it's rarely apples to apples but are
there elements from your favorite RPG
games that you have put into this
development yeah I would say our
approach and we looked at designing this
game is that we wanted to build
something that's kind of like a
Borderlands experience but with magic
yeah
and once the graphics always a big an
important aspect of that because a lot
of role-playing games you know you can
play D&D and have an incredible
experience but you know you can
visualize yourself a lot of classic
role-playing games don't necessarily
look incredible
and this looks like you know this looks
like bleeding edge technology were
looking at here was was that always was
that a fundamental part of trying to
make so you know our biggest sort of
pillar of game gameplay is literally
gameplay that moment-to-moment visceral
gameplay but may choose incurring engine
was a big part of getting what we have
visually so when we got that we were
like we have to be able to push the
limits of this engine right we've got up
and we did our environment team has just
really knocked it okay look good that's
pretty yeah that moon blew up it did you
blew up that moon yes and there's a
story behind that learn when you play
the game this area that josh is fighting
in right now are these challenges we
call loot rooms where you attack this
machine and you go through these
challenges of fighting these waves and
all the loot that comes from the enemy
yeah will go up into the machine and
steady to you okay and the only way to
get the loot is to defeat the encounter
it all goes away
and as more loot is added in the machine
it promotes so it can get higher you can
get to legendary quality okay you can
actually sometimes look up there see a
legendary in it and if you die you gotta
try it again
that's amazing so it seems to me like
this that's what that almost reminds me
of my time doing raids in Warcraft right
where I like you you sort of build
yourself up for this one right a counter
is this a game view I think people are
going to replay definitely our goal is
that if people want to put hundreds of
hours into this they can right we're
gonna have a lot of extra gameplay
perhaps it's the antithesis of aren't
you doing but I have to ask us there's
lots of people on Twitter asking is
there any multiplayer component to this
what's rare this is a single-player
experience right now being our first
title we wanted to make sure that we
could focus on that get it
yeah yeah that's fair enough explain
some of the moment-to-moment gameplay
that's happening here because so what's
interesting is the game has eight sigils
or spells schools that are all
fundamentally different right you can
craft them in a variety of ways we have
seven different ways you can create the
spells in how they're delivered right
we've got a lob that will give Splash
Damage or a targeted or setting traps
there's a lot of different ways you can
build it and then every spell it can be
fundamentally built differently so you
have destruction which is about damage
control which is about lasting effects
like freezing or burning over time and
then mastery which is about setting up
these big news and in addition to that
you know what you live for in a powerful
mage game is you want to see really epic
moments yeah we call those synergies so
one of the synergies that we have in
this new build is called singularity and
the way that that works is you achieve
over kills with your spell's and you can
set up the synergy and so josh is gonna
pull this off here when you get some
enemies lined up and it's a very epic
moment and normally when you see
something like that in the game what
happens it's on a cool-down
yeah through three four minutes or
something we don't put it on a cooldown
it's about gameplay you destroy your
enemies to get that synergy and then you
put it in play and just detonate surety
the range of spells you can you can make
must be like every time you've added a
new layer to that crafting system it
must of like exponentially growing as
the possible types of asperities crazy
there's a hundred and sixty eight levers
you can pull and you get very degree so
it's thousands of combinations how do
you see your community come up with
stuff and then you're like oh oh oh oh
oh that's that's a bit too crazy let's
let's or maybe this is a good idea but
we should expand on that a bit yes we
have we have some players that really
push the envelope definitely and what
are types of environments are there
within the game a lot of people are
asking we've seen the sort of the field
like the the pastoral look or the cave
so we've had on the lobby a couple of
weeks ago this is obviously more of an
Arctic tundra yeah what other types of
that so we've got you know a swampy area
we've got some barren wasteland some
really lush Oasis we've got a lot of
very very different different looks and
one of the interesting things about
most recently is that a lot of these
games that we have here maybe aren't out
but people can actually play them either
there are demos or the beta for
battlefield hardline was announced
yesterday and this of course is
available on Steam early access so can
people still get into that and
absolutely yes yeah the game is in early
access you can get it all the way up to
release and the price goes up
incrementally in fact the first price
increase is on Monday oh really yes so
tick-tock y'all yeah you can get it for
$19.99 right now and it's $39.99 and oh
really oh wow okay so it's gonna go up
$10 on one thing it's gonna go up $5 and
$5 on Monday okay $24.99 that's a how
many how many people are in that pool do
you know how many people are engaged
with the game and playing it right now
so we have a pretty avid community and
like I said we're very focused on the
forums we got a few thousand players
that are all you know giving us a lot of
feedback right and it's not on the steam
forums themselves or have your own you
know we do it all through Steam it's
incredible it's easier to stay in touch
with everybody that way did you how much
contact did you have with valve on doing
that or have you found early access to
be something you could do yourself
remotely it's very interesting because
we had not planned to do early access we
were just gonna do a release that it was
roughly in this timeframe and before the
GDC I went out to visit with valve and
they started talking to us about the
benefits you know the good and the bad
the ups and downs of early access and I
came back about two weeks four before
GDC and I told the team I thought a lot
about it I want to do early access yeah
and Tim Lindsey our design director
who's a veteran in the industry says hey
that's great maybe we'll do that in beta
and it's like no no I want to do it in
GC on two weeks and we pulled it off we
got it up there in two weeks and it's
been great I'm telling you we would not
have the game that we have right now
yeah if we didn't do this that's
incredible because usually I one of the
benefits it seems to be from our
perspective in the price at least and
maybe it's just maybe we have the
blinkers on is that early access seems
to be a really good way of just
generally promoting a game that's a game
that's good on its own
just by getting it in people's hands
right so do you think people do you
think there'd be this much interest in
balls around lists of homage if you guys
were just doing on a day this is our
video game yeah well you know and some
people have a good tolerance for it some
don't right for us what we want is
feedback from people in it right some
people just buy it and sit it on the
shelf to get at the reduced price
to wait for release to play it because
they're not interested in playing an
unfinished game yeah yeah but but that
that community feedback has been
fantastic excellent
so when it what about you guys are
launching and a little bit more details
about this Alfa diyaa bomb on that so we
have an alpha coming out on Monday
that's got a new boss new level a new
sigil the Lightning center that was
designed by the community also and and
then August 26 there's our release date
awesome Michael macmaine thank you so
much thank you pleasure to meet you I I
think richlum is a game that we've
really enjoyed in GameSpot I can't wait
for more people to see it and also just
hearing your story that you finally
managed to make the video game I dreamt
of your whole time right that's pretty
awesome so I best look with the really
solution battle mage thank you very much
for coming on the show